merci nous accorder ces quelques minutes
ça fait cinq ans déjà ce seuil et si
vous étiez premier ministre d'haïti à ce
moment là quels souvenirs personnels
garder de ce moment là beaucoup de
frustration
parce que on avait souhaité autre chose
après le 2 janvier on espérait pouvoir
reconstruire un nouveau pays et on
espérait donner beaucoup plus d'espoir à
cette population sur notre capacité en
tant que dirigeant de prendre en main
une reconstruction pour ce pays on a été
dans la pratique
un peu angle ou est englué dans une
gestion humanitaire et on a dit beaucoup
de difficultés j'ai l'impression et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à sortir de l'eau
mal d'humanitaire pour entrer dans la
rue il ya eu cet énorme élan de
solidarité
de la part de la communauté
internationale s'était sans précédent
sans précédent s'est tout de suite c'est
à dire que il ya un résultat il ya eu
beaucoup d'états je vous dis quand même
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à 1.5 millions
de gens dans les rues
très rapidement on s'est organisé pour
rester en communication avec eux et
c'est organiser ce qui est l essentiel à
l'époque
l'eau potable la nourriture et le plus
rapidement possible des structures de
logement je veux pas parler de logements
la structure le logement qui était
constituée essentiellement de tentes de
protection parce qu'on avait cartonné
relations qui étaient dans les rues
donc ça déjà ça a été une opération
extrêmement lourde peu de gens se
rendent compte que ce que veut dire
donner à boire à un million et demi les
gens chaque jour et pour des raisons
pratiques que c'était très coûteux parce
que c'était de bouteilles c'étaient des
choses qui étaient en parc t il fallait
transporter la logistique était très
compliqué mais n'empêche monsieur
bellerive quand même 5 milliards de
dollars versés en haïti sont pas versés
en haïti le 5 milliards de dollars
dépensés
dépenser mais donc ce prêt défense et
par la communauté internationale c'est
ce que vous voulez dire bon oui c'est à
dire que par exemple à la conférence à
new york le venezuela
que nous remercie vraiment qu'ils ont
été un pays qui aurait raccompagné a
ainsi vaincu cours du processus et
jusqu'aujourd'hui
promettent 1.2 milliard les conditions
favorables sont là et nous devons
réussir ça rentre dans les chiffres mais
dans les 1.2 milliards il ya 900 900
millions de l'immersion de la dette pour
ce n'est pas de l'argent que je peux
utiliser pour aider à la reconstruction
en tout combien d'argent a été versé
c'était très compliqué de faire ce
chiffre là parce que par exemple tiens
une structure qui décide que l finances
à travers cette des structures
nationales ong ou autre et qu'on va
financer
ou que la croix-rouge finances nous
n'avons pas un contrôle sur la
comptabilité de la croix rouge elle a
fait ses preuves marathon elle a trouvé
son argent et vient en haïti pour
répondre à des besoins et elle décide
quels sont les besoins qu'elle va
répondre en haïti et la coordination est
souvent très compliqué avec des
organisations internationales leur dire
écoutez nous ça ne nous intéresse pas
qu'on fasse et sa voix si notre client
termes de santé publique
si vous voulez construire un hôpital
ministre
je n'ai pas pu donner des coups j'ai dû
conduire des hôpitaux
dans un pays qui manque d'hôpitaux on
est plus arrivé on a dû arriver les
extrêmes où après trois mois de
discussions ont dit à une ong une agence
ça m'intéresse pas que vous construisiez
cet hôpital là parce que j'en ai un 400
m par contre dans telle zone aller aux
algériens si vous voulez construire un
hôpital vous allez là maintenant on
commence à construire quand même
l'hôpital malgré l'interdiction du
gouvernement et on se sert de la
population qu'elle ait besoin qui vient
commence à venir à l'hôpital qui vous
dit et maintenant une campagne qui se
faire on veut vous aider en entrant à
l'hôpital gouvernement dit non et honda
prend une mesure maintenant d'envoyer
des bulldozer pour construire pour
détruire l'hôpital dans un pays comme
haïti pour leur dire écoutez vous ne
pouvez pas faire
c'est absurde je vous le fais pas dire
ce que vous pensez c'est un vote de non
confiance envers les tahitiens d'avoir
décidé de gérer justement certainement
mais c'est quelque chose de récurrent
mais ça peut être expliquée de beaucoup
de façons moi je me suis rendu compte
qu'à chaque fois qu à un événement qui
justifie une augmentation de l'aide
externe et on vous reparle de corruption
on vous reparle d'incompétence mais dans
la pratique beaucoup de choses ont été
faits par ce gouvernement avec le peu
d'argent qu'il avait qui ont des
retombées jusqu'à aujourd'hui et quand
on parle de crise politique par ailleurs
on comprend un peu l'écrin de la
communauté internationale y avait une
crise politique en 2011 on est à nouveau
en crise politique aujourd'hui et ce
n'est pas une responsabilité quand même
des haïtiens de ton que vous ne donnez
pas vous ne permet pas aux forces
nationales aux forces institutionnelles
se renforcer justement faisant des
choses on aura toujours une crise
politique parce que la population elle
vote pour les gens pourquoi parce
qu'elle pense que ces gens là peuvent
répondre à des besoins que vous avez est
systématiquement on dit le message la
communauté nationale internationale
c'est qu'on ne leur donne pas l'argent
parce que ce sont des corrompus au
départ ces populations n'a plus
confiance en vous et très rapidement à
la fin de votre période où je n'avais
pas pu faire grand chose parce que vous
n'aurez payer les moyens de répondre à
ces besoins de la population et on a ce
qu'on appelle le phénomène du pendule on
parle mais on parle d'un extrême à
l'autre parce que même les forces
nationales disent ils n'ont rien fait à
moi il faut un moment donné le moins
fort miser sur le gouvernement miser sur
les institutions haïtiennes savoir qu'il
y aura des problèmes mais que au fur et
à mesure on va renforcer les capacités
du gouvernement et celle des astuces des
institutions haïtiennes de répondre aux
besoins de la population
tant qu'on va faire une politique en
parallèle de compensation le
gouvernement haïtien ne sera jamais fort
en terminant messieurs bellerive
quelques mois après le séisme vous êtes
passé à montréal et vous avez lancé un
appel à la diaspora haïtienne en disant
qu'elle devait être intégré au processus
de reconstruction
qu'est ce que vous lui dites aujourd'hui
mon message à cette diaspora c'est de
travailler beaucoup plus près des
structures gouvernementales quelle
qu'elle soit mieux comprendre quels sont
les plans d'investissement qui a ici
mieux comprendre la vision qu'a le
gouvernement sur le développement de ce
pays et voir comment ils peuvent
s'intégrer et être nous ambassadeurs
dehors je n'ai pas vraiment de rentrer
s'ils ont déjà fait leur vie autre part
il ya des haïtiens qui sont aujourd'hui
des canadiens ils ont un double amour je
leur dis pas laisser le québec est venue
en haïti mais je dis depuis le québec
que pouvez vous faire pour haïti est-ce
que vous avez une vision une compétence
des moyens réseau
essayant de le mettre ensemble merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup